This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO百分之，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the aha radio app apple podcast or wherever
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。并不意味着你需要收听在aha radio应用程序、apple podcast或任何地方的learn the hard way
you get your podcast hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we discuss some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology welcome back to the podcast everyone thank you for joining us again this week we've got a pretty exciting episode going on today and a very special guest welcome Claudia hi Gemma thanks for having me oh that's okay um so how do we know each other before we get into what we're talking about so so well we worked at boost together yeah when we both lived in melbourne yep like like five years ago yeah or five years ago yeah when you were still in high school yeah oh my god I was literally such a baby and you guys really took me under your wing it was so
大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在二十几岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转型及其对我们心理学意义的播客。欢迎大家再次回到播客，谢谢大家本周再次加入我们。今天我们有一集非常精彩的节目和一个非常特殊的嘉宾。欢迎克劳迪娅。嗨杰玛，谢谢邀请我。哦，没关系，嗯，在我们谈论的话题之前，我们是怎么认识的呢？我们在布鲁斯一起工作过。对，当我们俩都住在墨尔本的时候。对，就像大约五年前。对，五年前。当你在读高中时。对，天哪。我当时简直就像个婴儿，你们俩真的很照顾我。这太
I was your manager for a bit. Yeah, I know. You were my manager, and I used to always still protein balls. Yeah, I did too. Yeah, yeah. Don't tell our old boss that. Lay, are you listening? Our old boss.
我曾经是你的经理。是的，我知道。你曾是我的经理，而我过去常常偷蛋白球。是的，我也偷过。对，对。别告诉我们的老板。雷，你在听吗？我们的老老板。
I wonder what he's doing right now. I don't know. Hopefully he's happy. I think his boost juice shut down for the health code violations, most likely. But that's another story. That's another story. But basically, Carter and I knew each other when I was, significantly younger.
我想知道他现在在做什么。我不知道。希望他很幸福。我想他的boost juice很可能是因为违反健康规范而倒闭的。但那是另一个故事了。那是另一个故事了。但基本上，卡特和我认识的时候，我。明显要小得多。
You were also same the age of being younger, but I was little and you were a bit older than me. And then I moved to Sydney and we went out for dinner the other night. And as you do, we were like updating each other on
你当时也是年轻的年纪，但我很小，而你比我大一点。后来我搬到了悉尼，前几天我们一起出去吃晚饭。就像你所做的那样，我们一直在向对方更新
literally four years of our lives. And we started talking about our relationships as you do. And one in particular for you. Yeah. One of my relationship for a few years ago. Yeah.
буквально四年的人生。然后我们开始谈论我们的感情，就像你经常做的那样。其中一段对你来说特别深刻。是的。我几年前的一段感情。是的。
wasn't healthy to say the least. No. Yeah, I was listening to it in like genuine shock. Generally, yeah. I was speechless. And I was like, you know what? This is like something so prominent, like so common for women, especially in your 20s. Definitely.
至少可以说是不健康的。不。是的，我当时听得是真心的震惊。真的，是的。我当时说不出话来。然后我说，你知道吗？这就像是一件非常突出的事情，对女性来说非常普遍，尤其是在你二十多岁的时候。绝对的。
Like we were talking about when you don't have boundaries for yourself yet, you don't really know what you want. You're still discovering, dating and everything. Yeah. I also think it's really important because. You don't really know what it's like until you get into something and people don't talk about it enough, I think. So I was like, come on board. Yeah. Let's talk about toxic abusive relationships in our 20s, especially for, like we were saying, we can only really speak to a, like, a female perspective.
就像我们讨论的那样，当你还没有为自己设定界限时，你并不真正知道自己想要什么。你还在探索，约会以及一切。是的。我也觉得这真的很重要，因为。你直到亲身经历之前并不会真正了解那种感觉，而且人们对此谈论得还不够，我觉得。所以我就想，加入进来吧。是的。让我们来谈谈二十多岁时有毒的虐待性关系，特别是为了，就像我们说的那样，我们真的只能从女性的角度来谈论。
Yeah. And we aren't therapists. No. No, we're not. Yeah. So obviously, we both have degrees in psychology. Yeah. And I just finished my honors in psychology last year.
是的。而且我们不是治疗师。不。不，我们不是。是的。所以很明显，我们俩都有心理学学位。是的。我去年刚刚完成了我的心理学荣誉学位。
actually my research was in this kind of area as well. Yeah. Similar area. Should I link your thesis? So if you want to read it? Oh, it's not published. Oh, damn. It's so good.
实际上我的研究也是在这个领域。是的。类似的领域。我要不要链接你的毕业论文？如果你想读的话？哦，它没有发表。哦，该死。它写得太好了。
I like, she like sent it to me after dinner and I was like, oh, incredible reading. But yes, so obviously we're not licensed therapists. Yeah. But yes, I do have an honest degree. Yeah. In this area. In this area. So, like, I was reading her thesis and I was like, this is like, you know, I always try
我喜欢，她就像是在晚饭后发给我的，然后我说，哦，读起来太不可思议了。但是是的，所以很明显我们不是有执照的治疗师。是的。但是的，我确实有荣誉学位。是的。在这个领域。在这个领域。所以，就像，我读她的论文时就觉得，这就像是，你知道，我总是试图
make the episodes like really kind of research-based and I think like my I didn't really want to do this episode I think alone and like not have like someone else to kind of bounce ideas off of or another experience definitely um so this just seemed like the perfect yeah yes to have the perfect time to do it yes so we're going to get into it today talk all about toxic relationships so we've given you the whole story of how this episode came to be um we were having dinner and we were talking about our relationships. And Claudia, would you like to kind of give a bit of, yeah, like that story into what we were talking about.
让每集节目都真正基于研究，我觉得我的，我其实不想一个人做这一集，我觉得没有另一个人来一起碰撞想法或者没有另一种经历绝对是...嗯，所以这似乎是完美的，是的，是时候做了，是的，所以我们今天要深入探讨，讨论所有关于有毒关系的事情；所以我们已经把这一集是怎么来的整个故事都告诉了你们，嗯，我们当时在吃晚饭，然后我们在谈论我们的感情。克劳迪娅，你愿意讲一点，是的，就是那个关于我们谈论的内容的故事吗？
Yeah, yeah, but I was just telling Gemma, so I moved to Sydney in 2018 for uni. It was my first year of uni. I was living on campus, so like a whole street of houses that were all uni students. And the house next door to mine was like had a house of eight. and there was one of the people living in the house he was an exchange student and you know being the house next door we kind of became friends whatever
对，对，但我刚刚告诉杰玛，所以我是在2018年为了上大学搬到悉尼的。那是我上大学的第一年。我住在校园里，就像是一整条街的房子，全都是大学生。我隔壁的那栋房子里住了八个人。
hung out a bit I kind of knew what he was like you know you kind of tell I think we'll get into that a bit more later but you know very charming we became friends and because I kind of yeah I rejected him like pretty like at the start yeah yeah like he kind of kind of came on and I was like, no, like I had already dealt with little experiences of just
其中一个人是个交换生，你知道，作为邻居我们自然就成了朋友什么的，
kind of, you know, crappy dating experiences. So I was like, nah, I'm like here to kind of study and have fun. But because he was my friend, or I considered him a friend at the time, you know, I think he invited me out for breakfast one day, just as friends. So I thought, and it kind of turned, I guess, like more intimate, very fast. And I kind of thought because if we were friends, and he'd actually tried for a few months at this point to kind of get to know me and everything. Like, I obviously found him attractive. I was like, sure, maybe this could be a thing. Like, maybe I judged it too harshly or maybe because he's actually putting an effort.
一起玩了一会儿，我大概知道他是个什么样的人，你知道，你多少能看出来，我想我们稍后会更详细地讨论这个，但他非常迷人，我们成了朋友，而且因为我差不多，对，我在一开始就拒绝了他，非常直接，对，对，就像他有点主动出击，而我说，不，我之前已经经历过一些关于
And yes, he could have that tendencies. But if he really likes me, you know, it kind of was a whole, like, he's going to abandon being a fuck boy for me. Yeah. I can change him. Yeah. I can be the one. I can be the one, you know.
那种，你知道的，糟糕的约会经历的小插曲。所以我当时想，不，我是来学习和享受乐趣的。但因为他是我的朋友，或者说我当时把他当成朋友，你知道，我想他有一天邀请我去吃早餐，只是作为朋友。所以我以为，这发展得，我猜，变得更亲密的速度非常快。我当时想，既然我们是朋友，而且他当时其实已经花了几个月的时间试图了解我以及所有这些。显然我当时觉得他很有吸引力，我就想，好吧，也许这能成真。也许我之前对他的评价太严厉了，或者因为他确实付出了努力。
Makes him realize how to treat women. much wanting to be that and so when I kind of had my brain switched kind of to that and very quickly I was kind of in it and I wanted it and I wanted to be that and there was lots of things that happened throughout the year
是的，他可能有那种倾向。但如果他真的很喜欢我，你知道，这就变成了一个整体，比如，他会为了我放弃当海王。是的。我可以改变他。是的。我可以成为那个特例。我可以成为那个特例，你知道的。
you know we never made it one of the things was we never established that we were official we never wanted to put a label on it yeah you know so the typical kind of he could still get away with things under the guise of there's no label we're not official you're not my girlfriend.
让他明白如何对待女性。非常渴望成为那样的人，所以当我的大脑转向那种模式，而且非常快地，我就已经深陷其中了，我渴望得到它，我渴望成为那个人，这一整年里发生了许多事情
So, for, you know... But you pretty much are. You know, I considered it. In my head, it very much was. In my head, I wasn't seeing anyone else. I wasn't interested in anyone else. I was committed, like, I would be committed in a normal relationship, and that's what I wanted.
你知道，我们从来没有确定关系，其中的一件事就是我们从未确立过我们是正式情侣，我们从来不想给它贴上标签，对，你知道的，所以这就成了典型的，他仍然可以在“没有标签、我们不是正式情侣、你不是我女朋友”的幌子下为所欲为。
Yeah. But, you know, to him it was fun in games, really. To him, I was... Who knows? Who knows what I was to him? I don't have... I don't know. I probably think he doesn't even know.
所以，为了，你知道的……但你几乎已经是了。你知道，我是这么认为的。在我的脑海里，这非常像。在我的脑海里，我没有和别人约会。我对其他人也不感兴趣。我很投入，就像，我会在一段正常的恋爱中一样投入，而这正是我想要的。
He sounds like such a... Yeah. I still don't know to this day, but that's something you have to accept when you get into this. Yeah. but so basically he would kind of spring on every month or a couple of months that he went on a tinder date or he went on other dates for other women and so every time um you know i would hear that and be like obviously that's not okay yeah i am taking this seriously and you're not yeah so i would want to
是的。但是，你知道，对他来说这真的只是好玩和游戏。对他来说，我是……谁知道呢？谁知道我对他是什麽？我没有……我不知道。我可能觉得他自己都不知道。
end it i would want to get out of it and he had this way of making me feel bad for him and this is actually something i only realized very recently i was reading this book that my actually now boyfriend gave me when I finished my thesis, who's a sweetheart. Yeah, he's so lovely. He's lovely. So there's a good ending, everyone, before you hear all this tragic.
他听起来真是个……是的。直到今天我还是不知道，但这是你陷入这种关系时必须接受的事情。是的。但基本上，他大约每个月或每隔几个月就会突然说他去进行了一次Tinder约会，或者他和别的女人进行了其他约会，所以每次……嗯，你知道的，我听到这些都会觉得，显然这不对劲。是的。我在认真对待这件事，而你没有。是的。所以我想
Yeah, it's a good ending. I'm in a very healthy relationship now. Yay. Yay. But he gave me, anyways, he gave me this book on kind of sociopaths, basically, which is pretty much who I was dealing with,
结束它，我想摆脱它，而他有一种让我为他感到难过的方法，这其实是我直到最近才意识到的一件事，我当时在读一本书，那是现在已经是我的男朋友的人，在我完成论文时送给我的，他是个甜心。是的，他太美好了。他很好。所以大家在听到所有这些悲剧之前，有个好结局。
unknowingly at the time. And anyway, I was reading this book and one of the things that really stuck out to me, but I didn't really realize, because I still never really fully understood, what kept me in it. I knew it, I knew how bad it was. And there was a lot of things that happened.
是的，这是一个好结局。我现在在一段非常健康的恋爱中。耶。耶。但无论如何他给了我这本书，关于反社会者的书，基本上，这几乎就是我当时正在应对的人，
There was a lot. Like, there was a lot that happened that were. When you told me, I was like... Downright abusive and unacceptable. Oh, my God, I made me... I was so angry. I was like... Yeah.
当时并不知情。无论如何，我在读这本书时，有一件事真正触动了我，但我当时并没有真正意识到，因为我仍然没有完全理解，是什么让我留在那段关系里。我知道，我知道它有多糟糕。而且发生了很多事情。
And I can only imagine, like, yeah. Anyhow. There was a lot of things. That was a lot of things. So every time, and I kind of wondered to myself even years after, like, still the question lingered, like, how did he keep getting me back? I was ready every single time he said, I went on Tinder date, I had sex with this person. Like, every time I was like, that is it.
有很多。有很多事情。当你告诉我的时候，我简直……简直是虐待且不可接受的。哦，天哪，我气得……我太生气了。我当时想……是的。
We are done, I'm done, I had it all prepared. We would sit down to have a chat and somehow I would end up after that chat, not broken up with him, but back with him. Yeah, and feeling bad for him. And then so when I read this book, they said that the number one thing, they talked to someone who was in jail. It was a known psychopath. It was a psychologist talking to him. They said, what do you most want from someone? and what is it that you look for when choosing kind of victims almost?
我只能想象，是的。不管怎样。有很多事情。那有很多事情。所以每一次，甚至在几年后我还在问自己，这个问题依然萦绕不去，那就是：他是怎么把我重新勾回去的？每一次他说“我去进行了一次Tinder约会”、“我和这个人发生了性关系”时，我都准备好了。每一次我都想：够了。
And they thought that we're going to say, like, I want power, I want money, it's kind of control, whatever. He said, I want guilt. I want people to feel guilty. Because, you know what? When someone feels guilty, when someone feels sad for someone, all other emotions in a normal functioning human brain, go. Oh, my God. It's that powerful. And that is something that, oh my God, that's exactly what happened.
我们完了，我受够了，我都准备好了。我们会坐下来谈一谈，而不知怎么的，在谈话结束后，我不是和他分手了，而是又回到了他身边。是的，而且还为他感到难过。然后当我读到这本书时，他们说最重要的一点，他们采访了一个在监狱里的人。这是一个众所周知的精神病态者。一个心理学家在采访他。他们说，你从别人身上最想要什么？你在寻找什么样的受害者？
That's exactly what it did. Because my emotions were so, this is done. Yeah. This is done, clear cut. Like, I'm not stupid. Yeah. I wasn't stupid. I knew damn what was happening.
他们以为我们会说，我想要权力，我想要金钱，这有点像控制，诸如此类。他说，我想要负罪感。我希望人们感到内疚。因为，你知道吗？当一个人感到内疚，当一个人为某人感到难过时，一个正常运转的人脑中的所有其他情绪，都会消失。哦，天哪。它是如此强大。而那正是，哦，天哪，这正是发生的事情。
Yeah. Couldn't understand it. And then I read that and I was like, oh my God. And you feel bad for, if you feel pity for someone. Yeah. If you feel pity and guilty and kind of you have that sadness or pity for someone, you want to kind of then make it better. and you feel bad for them.
这正是它所做。因为我的情绪是如此，这结束了。是的。这结束了，干脆利落。就像，我并不蠢。是的。我并不蠢。我很清楚发生了什么。
You think they are actually a nice person. Yeah. So when they get you, when they, you know, because it was a typical spill of, you know, I'm sorry, I'm shit. Like this was what he kept, you know, saying every time. I'll change. It's a typical I will change.
是的。无法理解它。然后我读了那本书，我就想，哦，天哪。如果你对某人感到同情。是的。如果你感到同情、内疚，并且对某人有那种悲伤或同情，你就会想让事情变得更好。然后你为他们感到难过。
I'll change. I'm sorry. I've got to work out my shit. I've got a, you know, I've got shit to work on, la la, la, but I will do it. You know, you kind of, you as a normal person, you think they want to work. Yeah.
你认为他们其实是个好人。是的。所以当他们抓住你，当他们，你知道的，因为这是一套标准的说辞，你知道的，我很抱歉，我很烂。这就是他一直以来，你知道的，每次都说的话。我会改变的。这是一个典型的“我会改变的”。
They do. Because that's what you would do. Because that's what I would do, you know. Yeah. Oh, you see, they're acknowledging the fact that you want to work on it, they want to change, and you feel pity for them. You think, oh, what a sad kind of per-oh, you've had a fucked up childhood.
我会改变的。我很抱歉。我得解决我身上的烂摊子。我有，你知道的，我有烂摊子要处理，啦啦啦，但我会做到的。你知道，你作为一个正常人，你以为他们真的想去解决。是的。
Oh, you're a bit sad. Oh, especially, you know, he was in a new country by himself. Oh, it is. It's the pity party. And that's what they want. It's the pity party. Yeah. Well, I was like, it's so funny you said that because back when I was like 19,
他们确实想。因为那是你会做的。因为那是我会做的，你知道的。是的。哦，你看，他们在承认你想解决问题的事实，他们想改变，而你对他们感到同情。你心想，哦，多么悲惨的一种-哦，你有一个操蛋的童年。
I was like seeing this person. And it's like, you said that to me and I was just like, oh my God. That's like the exact same thing. Like, he would always like make up. this like really tragic reason why I had to come over and see him and like comfort him and like literally like basically like cuddle him like cuddle him to sleep and then he'd be like like the next morning like oh hey you can leave now yep exactly and I'd be like oh I really thought that I was going to block you and when you feel sad and pity for someone yeah it's insane it's
哦，你有点难过。哦，特别是，你知道的，他一个人在一个新国家。哦，确实如此。这就是卖惨。而这正是他们想要的。这就是卖惨。是的。好吧，当时我就想，你这么说太搞笑了，因为当我大约19岁的时候，
it is it takes over and it takes and then they're like oh and you feel bad and oh and then the next morning yeah literally same thing happened and it's like oh they'll kick you out yeah I I once had this time when he was like Oh, something really awful has happened to me And it was my birthday And I went over to this person's Like apartment And I was like, is everything okay?
我当时在和这个人交往。就像，你对我说了那个，然后我当时就想，哦，天哪。这简直是一模一样的事。就像，他总是会编造。这样一个非常悲惨的理由，为什么我必须过去看他并安慰他，就像，字面意思，基本上就是抱抱他——抱他入睡，然后第二天早上他就会说——哦，嘿，你可以走了，是的，完全如此，然后我就会想——哦，我真的以为我要把你拉黑，而当你为一个感到难过和同情时，是的，这太疯狂了，它
And he's like, no. And he's like telling me this whole story About something tragic. And I was like, okay, like I don't even care It's my birthday. Like I just like, I know I should be shitty at you But like I feel so bad for you. And then he, as soon as I have the opportunity to talk
真的是，它占据了主导地位，然后他们就会说——哦，你觉得很糟糕，哦，然后第二天早上，是的，字面意思上发生了同样的事，然后就像——哦，他们会把你踢出去，是的，我曾经有过这样一次经历，当时他说：哦，我发生了一件非常可怕的事情，那天是我的生日，我去了这个人的公寓，然后我说：一切都还好吗？
He goes on his phone And he interrupts me and he goes Oh, someone else is actually coming upstairs. Do you mind just going and waiting in the bathroom? Yeah. Oh my god. And I was like, what? He goes like, just go and wait in the bathroom. Like, my friend is coming upstairs. And it was another girl he was seeing. Yeah. And it was my birthday. And I was sitting in the bathroom. And then I just had this realization. And I was like, what the fuck? Am I doing here? And you do have those realizations. Yeah. Like, like, you're like, what the fuck? Yeah. And like one of the what the
他说，没有。然后他开始向我讲述一整套关于某件悲惨事情的故事。然后我说，好吧，我甚至不在乎，今天是我的生日。就像我只是，我知道我应该对你很不爽，但我太为你感到难过了。然后他，一等我有机会说话
fuck moments, which really should have been the end of the relationship, but for me was after this kind of back and forth of I'm going on Tinder dates and I'm kind of blah, blah, la, but I love you, whatever, bullshit. He had a party at his house, like, well, his housemates had a party, and he was like, to me, oh, I'm going to be late. And I was like, you know, it's your house. Where will you be? He said, again, going on the Tinder date, which was, you know, I'd heard it before.
他就拿起手机打断我，然后说：哦，其实还有别人要上楼。你介意去浴室等一下吗？是的。哦，天哪。然后我就想，什么？他说：就去浴室等一下吧。我的朋友正要上楼。那是他正在交往的另一个女孩。是的。那天是我的生日。而我正坐在浴室里。然后我突然意识到这一点。然后我就想，我他妈的在干什么？而你确实会有那种顿悟。是的。就像，就像，你会想，我他妈的在干什么？是的。就像那些“我他妈的”时刻之一，这本来应该是一段关系的终结，但对我来说，是在经历了这一系列的分分合合——“我要去进行Tinder约会”、“我有点胡言乱语，但我爱你，无论如何，都是狗屁”之后发生的。他在他家里开了一个派对，好吧，准确说是他的室友开了一个派对，然后他对我，哦，我要迟到了。我说，你知道的，这是你的家。你会去哪儿？他说，又是去进行Tinder约会，这你知道的，我以前听过。
And at this point, I was just a bit fed up. and I was like, all my friends are coming to this party. So I just said, I'll deal with like this later. But whatever you do, I said in one thing that you do, do not bring her back to this party. Yeah. Just don't do it. Yeah.
而此时的我其实已经有点受够了，我就想，我所有的朋友都要来这个派对。所以我只是说，我等下再处理这事。但无论你做什么，我一再强调的一件事就是，绝对不要把她带到这个派对上来。是的。千万别这么做。是的。
Like, I'm there. Yeah, that's like, I'm there. No, even though I didn't even word it like that. See, it's ridiculous. Like, it was like, oh, but my friends, it wasn't even like, I'm there. You owe me this respect. The person you've been seeing. I know.
就像，我在那儿呢。是的，那就像，我在那儿呢。不，尽管我甚至都不是这么表达的。看，这太荒谬了。就像，哦，但是我的朋友们，甚至都不是像，我在那儿。你欠我这份尊重。这个你一直在交往的人。我知道。
Anyway, it was, anyway, and he was like, what, do you think I'm stupid? like why would I do that? Of course I wouldn't do that and I was like, well, I've done many stupid things these months like, all right, but he was like adamant. Like, I would not do that. Party happens. All my friends were literally sitting in the lounge room in a circle, all around in a circle.
无论如何，当时是，不管怎样，他当时说：什么，你以为我很蠢吗？我怎么会做那种事？我当然不会那么做。我说：好吧，这几个月我做过很多蠢事，好吧，但他表现得很坚决。就像，我不会那么做的。派对开始了。我所有的朋友当时都围坐在客厅的一个圈里，大家围成一个圈。
He walks in the middle of us with this girl. Says hey, just looks, says hey, like so casually, barely acknowledges me. Says hey, and go straight upstairs to have sex with her. um yeah i've heard that before but i still like what the fuck yeah like it's just that was really like that would have hurt so much yeah and obviously there was hurt underneath it but all that came out was fear anger yeah so angry because most of the four months i was just sad i was sad you know every time this happened i'll just cry or go to my friends but this time i
他带着这个女孩走进了我们中间。打了个招呼，看了一眼，就说了声“嘿”，非常随意，几乎都没认出我。说了声“嘿”，然后直接上楼和她发生关系去了。嗯，是的，我以前听过这个，但我还是觉得——他妈的什么鬼？是的，就像——这真的很——那一定很伤人，是的，显然伤心是在底下的，但所有表露出来的都是恐惧、愤怒，是的，太生气了，因为那四个月里大部分时间我都很难过，我很难过，你知道，每次发生这种事我都会哭或者去找我的朋友，但这次我
i fucking cracked yeah and i you know everyone looked at me in shock and everyone was kind of like and I didn't know what to do and my friend you know that lived in that same house was like in a room at the time who was right next to his room so I kind of just went upstairs and obviously she hadn't just witnessed what happened
我他妈的崩溃了。是的，然后你（知道），所有人都震惊地看着我，每个人都觉得……而我不知道该怎么办，我的朋友，你知道的，住在同一栋房子里的那个，当时就在一个房间里，就在他房间隔壁，所以我基本上就上楼了，显然她刚刚目睹了发生的事情
so I went upstairs to tell her in a very you know angry tone you know being like what the fuck like he just did this this and this like oh my god so I was like pacing back and forth kind of just like ranting essentially and she just sat there like watching
所以我上楼去告诉她，用一种非常，你知道的，愤怒的语气，你知道的，就像“他妈的怎么回事，他刚刚做了这个、这个和这个，哦，天哪”，所以我当时在房间里来回踱步，基本上就是在发泄，而她就坐在那儿看着
this like very you know this is fair and then just like turned to me and was like a little louder Like his room was right next door He was in there Fucking the chick at the time But loud up Loud up
这，非常，你知道的，这很公平，然后转过身对我说，大声一点。就像他的房间就在隔壁，他当时正在里面和那个妞搞呢，但是大声点，大声点。
She kept telling me to go louder So I started screaming Yeah Screaming Like fuck you Like fuck you for ever telling me That you love me Fuck you for doing this
她一直让我大声点。所以我开始尖叫，是的，尖叫，像“去你的”，像“去你妈的，居然对我说你爱我，去你妈的，居然做出这种事”。
Fuck you for this And this Just everything that came out From the past four months For you know Everything And then I end up kicking in these door And like fuck you
去你妈的，这还有这个。过去四个月里涌现出的所有情绪，为了，你知道的，所有的一切。然后我最后气冲冲地踢开门，就像，去你的。
Yeah And then walk downstairs And at this point A couple of my other friends arrived Yeah And they're like Hey you know and I was like,
是的，然后走到楼下，这时候我的另外几个朋友也到了，是的，他们说：嘿，你知道的，而我当时
not in a mood to socialise whatsoever. And they're like, what the fuck happened? So I went into the kitchen and signed explaining it to them. Yeah. And then he comes into the kitchen. And so he's facing me and standing behind my friends. I don't see him. I just see him.
根本没有心情社交。他们说：到底发生了什么？所以我走进厨房，开始向他们解释。是的。然后他走进厨房。所以他面对着我，站在我朋友身后。我看不见他。我只能看到他们。
And they obviously realize that I'm looking at someone else. So they turn and see it's him. They all could they just kind of leave us in the kitchen? And I just look at him and I'm like, what the fuck is wrong with you? I just said, what the fuck is wrong with you? and all he has to say to that was he looks at me looks at my top that I was wearing it was a red top
他们显然意识到我在看着别人。所以他们转过身去，看到是他。他们所有人都可以，他们只是把我们留在厨房里。我看着他，然后说：你脑子是不是有毛病？我直接说：你脑子是不是有毛病？而他对此唯一的反应是，他看着我，看着我穿的上衣——那是一件红色的上衣，
looks back up at me a little smirk on his face and goes red looks nice on you and walks out that's it that's it after just like shattering my whatever fantasy I'd left of the relationship but still like after pretty much disrespecting me and like the biggest way I think anyone can really disrespect a person.
重新抬头看着我，脸上带着一丝假笑，然后说：“红色挺适合你的”，接着就走出了门。就这样。就这样。在刚刚粉碎了——无论我脑海中对这段关系的幻想还剩下什么——之后，依然在以最大、我想可以说是任何人能对一个人做出的最不尊重的方式不尊重我之后。
Oh my God, yeah. Like, literally you said, like, please don't do this. And he literally said, like, this is a boundary. Like, I didn't even dress the fact that he was on a Tinder date for God knows how many time. You went like, don't go on that date. I was like, I'll deal with that later because I was fed up at this point. And I was like, I just want to have fun. Honestly, I can't deal with this again.
哦，天哪，是的。就像，你明明说过，求你别这么做。而他字面上的意思就像，这是一个界限。我甚至没有去提他去进行Tinder约会的事，天知道那是第几次了。你当时说的是“别去那个约会”。我说我待会儿再处理这事，因为我当时已经受够了。我说我只想玩得开心。老实说，我没法再应付这个了。
And I just said, don't bring her in. Yeah. Just please. If you do anything. If you need to do that. If you need to do that. Go to hers. Yeah.
然后我只说了一句，别把她带进来。是的。求你了。如果你一定要做点什么。如果你非得做那种事。去她家吧。是的。
Honestly, go to hers and we'd do the whole spiel again. Yeah. sleeping with someone and whatever. Yeah. But like, that wasn't the end, was it? No. So, you know, it was a start.
老实说，去她家吧，然后我们又得重复整套说辞。是的。和别人上床，诸如此类。是的。但那并不是结束，对吧？不。所以，你知道的，这只是个开始。
I did block him and cut him off for a couple months, which was I think, you know, it's still big to do them at this point. So, yeah, after that, I, you know, I went back to my house for the rest of the night and didn't engage in any of it. And I did block him on everything. I didn't talk to him for two months. And it was good, you know?
我确实拉黑了他，并把他切断联系几个月，我认为这在当时仍然是一件了不起的事情。所以，是的，在那之后，我，你知道的，那天晚上剩下的时间我回了自己的家，没有再理会任何这方面的事。而且我在所有平台上都拉黑了他。我有两个月没有跟他说话。这挺好的，你知道吗？
I actually see, well, you know, I seen fine and I was fine because there was still a glimmer of hope and that's the thing. Like it wasn't yes I cut him off and yes I blocked him but I knew it was only because I was waiting for him you know I still wanted him to come to my house and like I'm sorry
我其实觉得，嗯，你知道的，我看起来很好，我也确实很好，因为心中依然存有一丝希望，这就是关键所在。就像，是的，我切断了联系，是的，我拉黑了他，但我知道那只是因为我在等他，你知道的，我依然希望他能来我家，然后说“对不起”，
beg for me back but realize what he lost you know I cut him off and I wanted him to realize what he had lost so badly yeah and it never happens it never happens I've done that so many times it never happened So obviously of two months of being like, I'm fine and cool and getting on with my life,
求我原谅他，意识到他失去了什么，你知道的，我跟断了联系，而我非常渴望他能意识到他失去了什么。是的，但这从未发生，从未发生过。我做过那么多次，但它从未发生过。所以很明显，在经历了两个月的“我很好、很酷、在继续我的生活”之后，
but him never, you know, never apologising, I ended up one night, drunk after a party, going back to his and, yeah, pretty much starting it again. Yeah. Yeah. And that was like the second chapter. This was the second chapter. This is the sequel. Yeah.
但他却从不，你知道的，从不道歉，结果某天晚上，我在派对喝醉后，又回到了他家，然后，是的，基本上一切又重新开始了。是的。是的。而这就好比是第二章。这是第二章。这是续集。是的。
The sequel to it, which essentially was just him saying that he was going to commit to me this time, which I think you think he did? I don't know at least I didn't know this time the time before he told me
它的续集，本质上就是他说这次他会对我专一，我想你以为他做到了？我不知道，至少这次我不知道。上一次他告诉我
that he was doing these things and this time I wasn't aware of them and I was with him a lot more so I don't think so but again who fucking knows
他在做这些事，而这一次我并不知情，而且我和他在一起的时间要多得多，所以我觉得没有，但话说回来，谁他妈知道呢。
who fucking knows anyway but because he wasn't obviously doing it as frequently and we were together a lot more it was a lot more covert than
谁他妈知道呢，不管怎样，但因为他显然没有那么频繁地这么做，而且我们在一起的时间更多了，所以这比
not so overt and kind of like oh I'm just having sex all these women it was this was one the really controlling behaviours came. This scary behaviours, I would say.
那种毫不掩饰、大张旗鼓地说“我正在和所有这些女性发生性关系”要隐蔽得多，这一次真正展现出的是那些真正具有控制欲的行为。那些可怕的行为，我可以说。
It wasn't really scary before. It was like I'm dealing with a really kind of fucked fuck boy. But then it became scary. That was when I was like, I'm in an abusive relationship. It wasn't like I was fucking around with this kind of toxic fuckboy from, you know, on exchange. Ha ha ha ha ha. First year of uni things.
以前其实并不算可怕。感觉就像我在和一个真的很烂的海王打交道。但后来它变得可怕了。那就是我意识到我正身处一段虐待关系中的时候。这感觉不再像是——我只是在和大学一年级时交换来的这种有毒海王瞎胡闹。哈哈哈哈哈。
Yeah. This was like real. And that's when I knew I had to actually find, get out. And what was some of the, you don't have to talk about it, but it was like? Um, yeah, so put downs for a lot. Like insults, little insults, I'm very confident in myself as well, and he knew that. And so he tried to get to me anyway. You know, he pinched my stomach one day, like, you need to go for a run.
是的。这感觉是真实的。而我当时就知道我必须真正找到出路。那么其中一些——你不必具体说，但大概是什么样的？嗯，是的，有很多贬低。比如侮辱，小小的侮辱，我对自己的外表也很自信，而他知道这一点。所以他还是想方设法来打击我。你知道，有一天他捏着我的肚子说：“你需要去跑步了”。
He said I was an 8 out of 10 because my butt could be better. Like, shit like that, you know, which I actually, I didn't ever get to me those things, because I am really confident and I know I'm attractive, so I was like, fuck you. But, you know, he still wanted to do it, and it's still horrible. What else? Oh, behaviour is like, I wouldn't even know. what I do. Like you don't, you don't. There's no logic to it, but he would go for being
他说我是8分（满分10分），因为我的屁股还可以更好。像这种鬼话，你知道的，其实这些话从来没有真正打击到我，因为我真的很自信，我知道自己很有吸引力，所以我当时就想：去你的。但是，你知道的，他还是想这么做，这依然很可怕。还有什么？哦，行为就像，我甚至都不知道。我做了什么。就像你不知道，你真的不知道。这没有任何逻辑可言，但他会从
kind of fine, in an all right mood to kind of shutting down, going into his room, not talking to me. The silent treatment really often. Stonewalling, yeah. Stonewalling. Which we talked about in last week. Yeah. He did something really horrible to me and he told me not to tell my friends about what he did. And when I was like, you know, fuck you, my life.
状态还好、情绪尚可，突然转变成彻底封闭自己、回到自己房间、不理睬我。非常频繁的冷暴力。筑墙行为，对吧？筑墙行为。我们上周刚讨论过。是的。他对做了一件非常可怕的事，并告诉我不准把这件事告诉我的朋友。当我说，你知道的，去你的，这是我的人生。
I can do whatever, you know, I told him. all my friends. Yeah, because you would. Because I would, and I wasn't, you know, that afraid of him. Like, I was like, you know, getting there, but I was like, fuck you, I'm telling my friends. And I had really a relationship with my friends. And they still, I hadn't really lied to them much, yeah,
我想做什么都可以，你知道的，我把事情告诉了。我所有的朋友。是的，因为你会的。因为我会的，而且我并没有，你知道的，那么怕他。就像，我正在逐渐不受控制，但我当时的想法是，去你的，我要告诉我的朋友。而且我和我的朋友们关系很好。而且我还没有对他们撒谎太多，是的，
about me being with him. They all knew that I was still with him. But when he found out that I told my friends, oh my God, like, complete, just like, nothing, like, silence. I was, like, walking in the street with him, like, begging him to talk to me. anything.
关于我还和他在一起。但当他发现我把事情告诉了我的朋友时，哦，天哪，完全就是，只是，什么都没有，一片死寂。我当时，就像，走在大街上，乞求他跟我说话。说点什么。
Like, let's just discuss this, talk through this. Like, a normal, like, people will try to be. Nothing. Looked at me dead in the face when I was, like, fucking begging him in the middle of the street and just kept walking. Nothing. Like, two days. It's, like, so manipulative.
就像，我们来讨论一下，把这事说清楚。就像正常人，人们会去尝试的那样。什么都没有。当我像个疯子一样在马路中间哀求他时，他面无表情地看着我，然后继续往前走。什么都没有。就像，整整两天。这真的是，太有操控性了。
So, just, like... Also, the fact that he's, like, now, like, what the fuck? It's, like, he can do whatever he wants. Like, he can bring back girls to his house and, like, he can, like, do things to you. But as soon as you, like, access to people... I know. You're the baddest.
太……只是……还有，事实上，他现在这样，就像，这他妈算什么？感觉就像他想做什么就可以做什么。就像他可以带女孩回家，而且他可以，就像，对你做各种事。但只要你，就像，向别人倾诉……我知道。你重新掌握了力量。是的。然后他就逃之夭夭了。而且还有，比如，这就是我开始意识到他那种人格的时候。他告诉我，他其实感觉不到爱或者恨。他说他感觉不到太多东西，基本上是在自动驾驶状态下运作。所以他简直就像是在说，我不知道怎么，就像，我感受不到爱。
You stand in your power. Yeah. Then it flies off. And there was also like, so for instance, this is when I started kind of realizing the kind of personality had as well. He told me that he didn't feel love or hate really. He said he kind of never felt much and kind of operate on autopilot. So he literally was like, I don't know how to, like, I don't feel love.
然后我说，不好意思，你说什么？是的。这就像是在我真正教育自己、了解这种人格类型之前，你知道的。以及什么是反社会者。这字面意思就是无法感受到爱，甚至无法感受到愤怒。其实什么都感受不到。只有自我保护的本能。
And I was like, sorry, what? Yeah. It was like before I was really like educated myself, you know, on this kind of personality type. And what a so surreopath is. Which is literally the inability to feel love or even anger. Anything, really. It's just kind of... The only thing you feel is self-preservation.
是的。所以这对我来说很震惊。我脑子转不过弯来。我当时想，什么叫你在自动驾驶？就像我只是随波逐流地度过人生吗？就像，我永远不会对你产生爱，差不多就是这样。就像，我无法爱你。我永远也不会。
Yeah. So it was shocking to me. I couldn't wrap my head around. I was like, what do you mean you're on autopilot? Is I kind of just float through the motions of life? Like, I will never feel love for you, pretty much. It was like, I can't love you. I never will.
而且我从来没有，像，这种感觉。然后我说，那是……什么？是的，当时你的反应是——我当时就想，什么意思？就像，你必须有这种感觉，对吧？你是个活人。是的。你总得爱某个人吧。
And I never, like, feel this. And I was like, that's... What? Yeah, you were like, I was like, what do you mean? Like, you have to, right? You're a person. Yeah. You have to love someone.
你必须爱点什么，我是这么想的。不，根本没有。所以不管怎样，他从来没说过——哦，其实他在恋爱刚开始的时候确实说过他正在爱上我，但不管怎样。是的。无论如何，他当时说，你知道的，我对你有爱意，
and you have to love something, so I thought. Nope. And so anyway, he never told me, well, he actually did say he was falling in love with me right at the start of the relationship, but anyway. Yeah. Anyway, he was like, you know, I got love for you,
但我不是在爱着你，他总是这么说。而我甚至就接受了这一点。我甚至还是直接接受了。我心想：太棒了，就是这样。是的，当时我还想：哦，太绝了。然后有一天，他，哦，当我在精神上开始准备提出分手、当我开始在精神上与他拉开距离的时候。
but I'm not in love with you, is what he'd say. And I even just accepted that. I even still just, I honestly like accepted that. I was like, great, that's it. Yeah, and I was like, oh, brilliant. And then one day, he, oh, when I had started it mentally, kind of preparing to break it off when I started mentally kind of detaching myself.
因为此时你已经感到相当害怕了。是的，是的，是的。到这个时候，这大约是在我真正彻底结束这段关系之前的几个月。我开始在精神上做好准备，你知道的。在你真正付诸行动之前，你真的必须做一番心理建设，做好心理准备。你必须真正开始在情感上与对方解绑。而这正是我开始做的事情。老天爷，他们他妈的能感觉得到。
Because at this point you were like quite afraid. Yeah, yeah, yeah. At this point, this was like a couple months before I did properly end it. I was starting to mentally prepare myself, you know. You really have to do the mental game, preparing the mental game before you actually do it. You have to really start detaching yourself emotionally. Which is what I started doing. And God, they can fucking sense it.
真的吗？瞬间就能感觉到。真的。他们很擅长看穿别人。这就是为什么他们能把人看透得那么彻底。仅仅通过我行为中的一些细节，我不再那么容易受到他所说的话的影响，我对他的存在也不再那么在意了。
Really? Instantly. Really. They can read people. and that's why they can read people so well. Just the only things in my behaviour, I wasn't as affected by what he said, I wasn't really bothered by his presence so much.
我们当时基本上就是在一起消磨时间，我开始在社交时表现得更像平时的自己，不再那么投入，也不再那么担心他对我和我周围的事情做了什么。这感觉非常……所以我正在解离。而就在我这么做的那一秒，我知道他感觉到了，因为他随后把我带到楼上
We're kind of just hanging out and I started being a bit more like my normal self around and not so invested and so worried about what he was doing to me and what he was doing around me. It was kind of very, so I'd detaching. And the second I did that, I knew he could sense it because he then brought me upstairs
并告诉我他爱我，这正是我一直以来所期望的，对吧？是的。所以像个傻子一样的我。也不能算傻子，我不应该说自己蠢，但，你知道的，傻里傻气地，当我开始解离时，我其实只解离了一丁点。所以当他这么说时，我又立刻陷进去了。是的。
and told me he loved me, which is what I'd been hoping for for the whole time, right? Yeah. So me, stupidly. Not stupidly, I shouldn't say I'm stupid, but, you know, sillily, when I started touching, it was only like a tiny bit that I started. So when he said that, bounce right back in. Yeah.
哦，天哪，他说他爱我。哦，天哪，终于成功了。我让他爱上我了。是的。我让他明白了。但很明显，因为我不蠢，我还是转过身对他说：“你三天前才刚对我说过你不会爱，而且你永远也感受不到爱。”
Oh my God, he said he loved me. Oh, my God, finally it worked. I made him love me. Yeah. I made him realize. But obviously, because I'm not stupid, I still did turn around to him and say, you told me three days ago that you cannot love and you will never feel love.
“那你为什么突然——而且这字面意思，就在三天前——为什么你现在突然对我说你爱我？”是的。然后他看着我，说：“管好你自己。”接着他说：“别得寸进尺。”哦，天哪。哦，天哪。别得寸进尺。
So why are you suddenly, and this was literally, it was three days before that, why are you suddenly telling me that you love me now? Yeah. And he looked at me and said, watch yourself. And he said, don't push it. Oh my God. Oh, my God. Don't push it.
然后就把我晾在一边三天。字面意思上在接下来三、四天里对我不理不睬。是的。完全忽视我，什么都没有。我当时甚至以为他大概死了或者怎么着，因为他直接断联了。哦，天哪。我当时快疯了。
And then ignored me for three days. Literally ignored me for the next three, four days. Yep. ignored me nothing. I literally thought he was like dead or something because he just cut it off. Oh my God. And I was like freaking out.
我急得像热锅上的蚂蚁。我心想：他妈的到底怎么回事？他没事吧？我完全联系不上他。而他大概只是在想，哦，只是……我当时急得连我妈和我的朋友们都说：去他家看看吧。是的。因为我甚至发了信息。
I was beside myself. I was like, holy fucking shit. Like is he okay? Like I haven't heard from him at all. And he's just probably just like, oh, just. I was so beside myself that my mom and like my friends were like, go to his house. Yeah. Because I even messaged.
然后我给他的室友发了信息，问：“你看到他了吗？”室友说：“对啊，他在附近。”然后我说：好，就这样。是的。去了他家。而且，整个人情绪崩溃。而他只是，像刚打完篮球回来，一脸“你在干什么”的表情。
And then I messaged his housemate being like, have you seen him? Like, he was like, yeah. He's around. And I was like, right, that's it. Yeah. Went to his house. And, like, beside myself. And he just is, like, coming back from playing basketball and being, like, what are you doing?
而我说：你，他妈的怎么回事？我一直联系不上你。就像，你为什么突然——整整三天？而他却说：哦，我只是需要一点独处时间。居然这么说。就像，不。显然根本不是因为那个。
And I was like, you, what the fuck? Like, I haven't heard from you. Like, why have you suddenly, like, three days? And he was like, oh, I just needed to have some alone time. Say that. Like, yeah. Like, no. And obviously it wasn't because of that.
现在我意识到是因为我质疑了他。而当你去质问一个，你知道的，自恋狂、反社会者，随你怎么叫他们吧。是的。当你质疑他们的行为时。是的。轰。就像，是的。不管怎样。
Now I realize it was because I questioned him. And when you question, you know, narcissist, so past, whatever you want to call them. Yeah. When you question them on their behaviors. Yeah. Boom. Like, yeah. Anyway.
现在我意识到是因为我质疑了他。当你质疑一个自恋狂或不管你怎么称呼他们的人时，是的。当你质疑他们的行为时。是的。砰。就像，是的。总之。
And then what happened after that? And then... How did you end up? I ended up just getting more and more anxious around him, really. It was more my body. My body's response to him because I just, yeah, it was just a complete shit show. And I ended up just getting, like, anxious. And then I went overseas with my friends for a week.
然后后来怎么样了？然后呢……你最后怎么变成那样的？我其实最后就是对他越来越焦虑。更多是我的身体。是我身体对他的反应，因为我，对，那简直就是一团糟。我最后变得，就，很焦虑。然后我和朋友去海外待了一个星期。
Just before COVID, obviously. Yes, obviously. and reset, I guess, for my body. You know, reset. I had honestly not spent much more than a few days away from him in a three-month period. Yeah. So kind of like, yeah, getting myself away from that space
显然是在新冠疫情爆发前。是的，显然。然后我觉得我的身体算是重置了。你知道的，重置了。说实话，在三个月的时间里，我和他分开的时间加起来几乎不超过几天。对。所以就好像，对，让自己离开那个空间，
and just hanging out with my friends. Yeah. Kind of really just like, I was like, I could breathe. And so everything reset for a little bit and the moment I went back to him and, you know, back from overseas, that was it. I freaked, like, my body just freaked out. Like, I couldn't be next to him without feeling like,
然后和朋友们一起玩。对。就真的感觉，我就觉得，我能呼吸了。所以一切都稍微重置了一下，而当我回到他身边，你知道的，从海外回来后，就是那样。我吓坏了，我的身体简直吓坏了。我简直不能待在他旁边，否则就会觉得，
I was going to be a panic attack. My anxiety was through the roof. Yeah. Like, I just couldn't sit with him. I couldn't be with him. And I, you know, initially I was like, whoa, like, is this me? Like, I was just kind of like, I can't. I'm so anxious.
我快要恐慌发作了。我的焦虑情绪简直飙升到极点。对。就像，我根本无法跟他坐在一起。我无法和他在一起。而且我，你知道，一开始我还想，哇，这是我吗？我当时就觉得，我做不到。我太焦虑了。
And so I went and saw a psychologist. Yeah. And I was like, you know, I'm so anxious around my boyfriend. Yeah. I don't know what's happening to me. And she was like, okay, like, explain kind of just your relationship a little bit. Yeah. What's been going on?
于是我去看了一位心理学家。对。然后我就说，你知道的，我在我男朋友身边感到好焦虑。对。我不知道我怎么了。她说，好吧，那你简单解释一下你们的关系。对。最近发生什么了？
I talked for like a minute. or two. Yeah. And she just was like, I just could tell she was like, oh boy, and I'm a professional matter. And she just said, look, I have a hypothesis that he's a narcissist, you know? Yeah. This is a personality disorder.
我讲了一分钟左右。或者两分钟。对。然后她就，我能看出来她觉得，哦天哪，而且我是以专业人士的身份。她直接说，听着，我有个假设，他是个自恋狂，你知道吗？对。这是一种人格障碍。
It's not my client, but a hypothesize that he is. And like, so as you, like, we both studied psychology and like, you don't normally diagnose someone from someone else's assessment. You don't. It's like pretty much just not. It's pretty much. You don't do it. You learn in ethics.
这不是我的客户，但我假设他是。而且，就像你一样，我们都学过心理学，你通常不会根据别人的评估去诊断某人。你不会的。基本上就是不能。差不多就是这样。你不会这么做。这是你在伦理课上学到的。
Yeah. Like, you can't talk on behalf of something. So it's like, you have to be, so you have to be pretty fucking certain to say something like that. You have to be pretty fucking like scared for also my well-being to actually say something like no. Yeah. Like really clearly. Because I normally psych, I've never had a psych since that's been quite so like direct.
对。比如，你不能代表某种情况发言。所以，你得，所以说出这样的话必须要有相当的把握。为了我的安全，你也必须感到相当害怕，才会说出这样的话。对。非常明确地。因为我通常看心理医生，我从来没见过哪个心理医生这么直接的。
But she, anyway. Well, it's also the situation I think. Yeah. Yeah. You're actually like in danger here. Yeah. Like this person is like jeopardizing your physical and your mental health. Yeah.
不过她，总之。嗯，我想这也是因为当时的情况。对。对。你其实处于危险之中。对。这个人正在危及你的身体和心理健康。对。
you are like it's not good yeah exactly so yeah so she said you know I have a hypothesis that he's a narcissist and she very clearly goes you have two options in this situation one this is your life you stay with him and this is your life he's not going to change accept it right now no change this is him this is how he is
你就像，这可不好，对，完全如此。所以，对，她就说，你知道我有个假设，他是个自恋狂，然后她非常明确地指出，在这种情况下你有两个选择：第一，这就是你的人生，你和他在一起，这就是你的人生，他不会改变，现在就接受这一点，不要改变，他就是这样，他就是这副德行，
you stay this is your life two you leave that's it there's no in between there's no in between this is your life or you like yeah leave you make a decision and you like leave. I remember you telling you saying that to me and like the other day and like
你留下来，这就是你的人生；第二，你离开，就是这样，没有中间选项，没有中间选项，要么这就是你的人生，要么你就像，对，离开，你做一个决定，然后像，离开。我记得你把这番话告诉我，就像前几天，然后像
I was thinking about a situation I'm currently in and I'm like wow like either I keep entertaining this person and like just feel awful about myself all the time and like constantly like in a state of anxiety survival basically
我在想我目前处的状况，我就觉得，哇，要么我继续应付这个人，然后就像，整感觉糟糕透顶，而且就像，基本上一直处于焦虑和求生的状态，
and be like oh my god like how come I just want to be with you so much and you obviously don't even give a shit about me yeah and I was like either I keep this up or I just like I let it go. And I, like, you said that to me and I don't, this relationship obviously isn't, like, abusive or... It's a little bit.
然后心里想，天哪，为什么我这么想和你在一起，而你明显根本不在乎我。对。当时我就想，要么我继续这样，要么我直接放手。然后，就像你对我说的那样，我不觉得这段关系明显是，比如，虐待性的，或者……稍微有一点。
A little bit toxic. Yeah, but it's not like, to this degree. And, yeah, it was like, you said that to me and I was like, fuck, like, wow, like, it's my decision. Yeah, like, it really puts a control. Yeah, because the whole time the control is not with you. No. The control's not with you.
稍微有点有毒。对，但还没到这种程度。然后，对，就像你对我说的那样，我当时想，操，哇，这是我的决定。对，这真的把控制权交回了。对，因为整个过程中，控制权都不在你手里。没错。控制权不在你手里。
Everything is with them. Because they know, like, this person isn't like this, like, no at all, but like, I don't. but like I think when you're the one who loves that other person more, like you're never going to be like, I want to stop seeing you. Yeah, and that's the thing as well. Because you're not ending it because the love is gone or it kind of just fizzled out or you're doing different things.
一切都在他们手里。因为他们知道，比如，这个人其实不是这样的，一点也不，但我不知道。不过我觉得当你才是那个更爱对方的人时，你永远不会主动说，我不想再见你了。对，问题也正在这里。因为你结束这段关系不是因为爱消失了，或者它只是自然消磨掉了，或者你们在做不同的事情。
Like you're ending it because it's not healthy for you. No. Like, and yeah. For the stage of life that you're in either. No, just ever. But yeah. Yeah. Well, especially when I had the biggest semester of uni.
你结束它，是因为这对你不健康。没错。就像，而且，对。也不符合你目前处的人生阶段。不，根本就不符合。不过，对。对。特别是我还要应付大学里最忙的一个学期。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But you did it. I did. I was so, like... Yeah, I started breaking away and... Yeah, I pretty much... I started uni that week.
对。对。对。但你做到了。我确实做到了。我当时，就……对，我开始抽身离去，然后……对，我基本上……我那天刚好开学。
And I had a very busy semester coming up and I knew that and I just was very anxious and I just had to like... Yeah. Put it in. I had to say like, I'm ending this and I had to stick to it and I had to just block him. And that's really like... But then he started... Yeah. Showing up at your apartment.
而且我接下来有一个非常忙碌的学期，我心里很清楚这一点，我当时非常焦虑，我不得不……对。下定决心。我必须说，我要结束这一切，我必须坚持下去，我必须直接把他拉黑。这真的就像……但接着他开始……对。出现在你公寓楼下。
Oh, yeah. Sorry, it doesn't end then. Like, you have to be so, like, strong to stick with yourself, I think. And, you know, I did go back, like, once, you know. You go back a little bit at the start. You ended, and then I think we slept together, like, a couple times. But it was really my body. And it was, like, the anxiety stopped me.
哦，对。抱歉，还没结束。我觉得，你必须表现得非常坚强，才能坚持自我。而且，你知道的，我确实回去过，比如，一次，你知道。一开始你还是会回头一点点。你结束了，然后我觉得我们好像还睡过几次。但真的是我的身体。而且，焦虑感阻止了我。
It really was. It wasn't my, like, mental state 100%. But my body could not handle his presence anymore. Like, your brain was the true of danger. It was, like, a fucking alarm going off in my body. It honestly was. Like, I couldn't, like, the anxiety that I experienced being in his presence and anything was to do with him.
真的就是这样。这不是我的精神状态100%能控制的。但我的身体再也无法承受他的存在了。就像，你的大脑发出了危险的信号。就像，我体内拉响了一个该死的警报。真的就是这样。比如，我无法，我在他身边感到的焦虑，任何与他有关的事，
Yeah. Was, like, so severe that I had to just not see him. Yeah. Like, it really was my only choice. Yeah. So it was good in that sense. Like, that's when the body really knows. Yeah.
对。都太严重了，我只能选择不见他。对。这真的是我唯一的选择。对，从这个意义上说这也挺好的。这就是身体真正知道的时候。对。
I think it's when it's really important to listen to your body. Like the biofeedback. Yeah. 100%. Yeah. Yeah. Obviously, it's like that feedback loop that from everything. Yeah.
我觉得最重要的是倾听身体的声音。就像生物反馈一样。对。100%是的。对。对。显然，这就是来自一切的反馈循环。对。
But, yeah. But then, yeah, obviously, because I had obviously tried to end it a lot throughout, like, this almost year period. He knew that. He knew I said this is done and gone back. So he thought this was just another one of those instances. I was like, oh, yeah, okay, I'll give you a bit of space and then come on back and we'll have the same chat and we'll go back straight in.
但是，对。不过后来，对，显然，因为我在这将近一年的时间里，显然尝试过很多次结束这段关系。他很清楚这一点。他知道我说过“这结束了”然后又回去了。所以他以为这只是又一次那种情况。我想，哦，好吧，我给你一点空间，然后你再回来，我们聊一聊，然后一切又回到原点。
But the only thing to calm down my anxiety was completely detached and to try and mentally detached from him as well. So he tried to do this big grand gesture like a few weeks after I'd ended it. Which is typical. This is the love bombing. This is love bombing. This is love bombing. everyone. Love bombing.
但唯一能平息我焦虑的方法就是彻底抽离，并试着在精神上也和他切断联系。所以在我结束这段关系几周后，他试图搞一个非常盛大的求和姿态。这是典型套路。这就是爱的轰炸。这是爱的轰炸。大家注意，这就是爱的轰炸。
You probably see it on Instagram a lot, but like, it's fucking serious thing. It's a serious thing that they do to get you back or in. They do it at the start a lot, but also this is at the end. It can happen any time. So he gave me kind of, so throughout our year kind of together, he had
你们可能在Instagram上经常看到，但它真的是个很严重的事情。这是他们为了把你拉回或套牢而做的一种严重手段。他们在一开始经常这样做，但这也是在结束的时候。任何时候都可能发生。所以他给了我一种，所以在我们在一起的这一年里，他
sold my 21st birthday presents. He, you know, the things I asked for for Valentine's Day, which literally one rose he didn't get for me. So he never got me anything, basically. And so all at once, he brought me all the kind of gifts and things that I'd requested throughout the year at once, like in my room, it set it up.
卖掉了我21岁生日礼物。他，你知道的，我情人节要求的东西，连一朵玫瑰花他都没有给我买。所以他基本上从来没送过我任何东西。然后，他一下子把我这一年来要求的所有礼物和东西全都拿来了，就在我房间里，把它们摆好。
And was like, ta-da, basically. Like, look what I've done. Da-da-da. Ready. Ready to take me back. And I just, like, stood there. And I just, I couldn't even entertain the idea anymore. Because otherwise, I'd freak out. So I was like, no.
然后基本上就像是，噔噔，看我做了什么。哒哒哒。准备好了。准备好接受我了。而我只是，就站在那里。我甚至无法再考虑这种可能性了。否则，我会抓狂的。所以我说，不。
And I was like, you know, and I just said to him, sit down. And I was very, like, sternly kind of said, this was, like, never what I wanted. Obviously, yes, I wanted these gifts. that's nice. It would have been great. It would have been nice, you know,
然后我，你知道的，我只是对他说，坐下。我非常，就像，严厉地对他说，这从来都不是我想要的。当然，是的，我想要这些礼物。那挺好的。那本会很棒的。那本会很好的，你知道的，
to feel a little ounce of love. Oh my God, yeah. Especially when you were doing so much for him. Yeah. But it's not about, obviously, it's not about the material. No. It's not it. So I was like, this is not it.
去感受哪怕一丝一毫的爱。哦天哪，对。特别是当你为他付出那么多的时候。对。但这显然不是关于物质的。不。根本不是这回事。所以我当时说，这不是重点。
Yeah. This is never, this was never what it was about. This material stuff, which is obviously the only thing they can really relate to these people as well. Yeah. A lot of it's material stuff because they don't know anything about their emotions. Yeah. But I like sat down. I was like, all I ever wanted was stability.
对。这从来都不是，这从来都不是关于这些的。这些物质的东西，显然也是这些家伙唯一能真正与之产生共鸣的东西。对。很多东西都是物质的，因为他们对自己的情绪一无所知。对。但我坐下来。我说，我一直想要的只是稳定
and consistency. Simple, healthy, stable, consistent relationship. That's all I ever wanted. It's all I ever asked of you. And that was like, his face was like perplexed. Well, you said this to me. You were like, when you call out something like this,
和一致性。简单、健康、稳定、一致的关系。这就是我一直想要的。这就是我对你的全部要求。然后他的表情就像是困惑了。对了，你之前也对我说过这个。你说过，当你指出这样一件事时，
they get so confused. When you tell them no. When you just tell them no and you're really, it's like unemotional as well. They can't understand. Like they're really thrown off. And it's kind of, in a way, kind of funny, like seeing him the first time not in control
他们会感到非常困惑。当你对他们说不的时候。当你直接对他们说不，而且表现得非常、就像是毫无感情的时候。他们无法理解。就好像他们彻底被整懵了。从某种程度上来说，这其实挺搞笑的，就像看到他第一次失去了掌控一样。
because their control is back with you. you see when you take the control back from them and put it within yourself and actually make choices and say no and you know they're like what like what do you mean yeah you're saying no to me like it's yeah it's they just don't understand because it's like they never can compute what they really did it's weird but yeah so i just kind of kept saying no and you know he did try a few times he kept turning up my house you even tried to break into my house at one point lied to my house saying we were all contact, saying I was home when I wasn't home, that he could come in. Which is the lying and like the manipulation of other people around you as well.
因为他们的掌控权回到了你手里。你知道的，当你从他们那里把掌控权拿回来，并把它放回你自己身上，真正地做出选择，说不，你知道的，他们会一脸“什么？什么意思？”“哈？你在对我说不？”就感觉，这简直——他们就是无法理解，因为这就像是他们永远无法计算或意识到自己到底做了什么一样。这真的很怪，但总之——所以我只是不断地对说不，而且你知道的，他确实尝试了好几次，他不断地跑来我家，甚至有一度还试图擅闯我的家，给我家打电话说我们都在联系，说我明明不在家却说我在家，说他可以进来。这其实就是谎言，也是对你身边其他人的操控。
Just like trying to get whatever he could to get at me and the answer was constantly no. And that's really what you have to do. You just have to break it off. And it's really, it's easier said than done. Like, yes, I did it. They have a bit of a choke hold on you. But, yeah, the emotions for like the first three months, I would say in pretty much the first three months
就好像是在试图榨取他所能得到的一切来针对我，而我的回答永远都是“不”。这真的是你必须去做的。你只能选择彻底断联。这真的、说起来容易做起来难。没错，我是做到了。他们对你多多少少还是有一种精神禁锢的。但是，说真的，那种情绪大概在前三个月里——我可以说基本上就是在前三个月里
for the entire first semester of uni even though while I was doing uni and surviving as a matter like my emotions were all over the place. God. It's like going not that I've ever done hard drugs or been a drug addict but I would imagine it's like going cold turkey. Yeah. It is though
甚至在大学的整个第一个学期里，尽管我当时还在上大学，还在咬牙坚持，但我的情绪简直一团糟。天哪。这感觉就像是——并不是说我曾经吸过毒或者当过瘾君子，但我猜这感觉就像是吸毒者突然戒毒。没错。确实如此。
it is. It's an addiction in the brain. It is because it's an addiction in the brain and it's like cutting off a source of dopamine. Dopamine. It is. It's cutting off a huge source of dopamine. Also like it's cutting off a source of like norapherine and like your stress hormones and those are like quite addictive to your brain it's like why people take a lot of risks and why people do things like that and so when your brain it's like all of your neurotransmiticine hormones have been in this
确实是这样。这是一种大脑上的成瘾。就是这样，因为这是大脑的一种成瘾机制，就像是切断了一个多巴胺的来源。多巴胺。就是这样。这切断了一个巨大的多巴胺来源。同时，这也切断了去甲肾上腺素之类的压力激素的来源，而这些激素对你的大脑来说其实相当容易上瘾，这就是为什么人们会冒很多风险，为什么人们会做出那种事，所以当你的大脑——就像是你的所有神经递质和激素都处于这种
state of heightened arousal and now you're like you're crashing exactly and because when you're in this situation you're these hormones and your emotions are so tied to the person and what they do to you like they will you know you'll get euphoric you'll get these amazing euphoric highs when they give you some crumbs of good behavior or them. They are in a good mood. You will be euphoric and it's amazing and that's, but they do something bad and you'll come crashing down like the biggest low. And so it's like when your emotions are so up and down based on this other person and they're being regulated only in this way, when you cut off that source, they have nothing to respond to anymore. They don't have that stimulus. They're trying to
高度兴奋的状态，而现在你却像是在——你正在经历崩溃，确实如此。因为当你处于这种状况时，这些激素和你的情绪与这个人以及他对你做的事紧紧捆绑在一起，比如他们会——你知道的，当你从他们那里得到一点好行为的残羹冷炙时，你会产生极度亢奋的感觉，会体验到这种惊人的欣快感。只要他们心情好。你就会感到欣快，这感觉棒极了，那就是——但只要他们做了什么坏事，你就会像坠入谷底一样狠狠地摔下来。所以，当你的情绪完全根据这个人而起伏，并且仅仅以这种方式被调节时，当你切断了这个源泉，他们就再也没有什么可以回应的了。他们没有了那种刺激。他们还在试图
still go up. They're trying to still go down. Yeah. But when you don't have that response, And when you're not fighting against something, the only thing you can really do is just kind of cry and be a mess. Like, there's nothing to respond to, but they're still wanting to. That's what I had, like, with this other person, it was like, not that I think one of the disclaimers we wanted to give is, like, I think two people can be toxic for each other, but aren't necessarily bad people.
继续亢奋。他们还在试图继续低落。没错。但是当你没有了那种反应，当你不再跟什么东西对抗时，你唯一能做的其实就只有哭泣和一团糟。这就好像，没有什么需要回应的了，但他们却依然想要回应。我当时就是这种感觉——跟另一个人在一起时，就好像——并不是说我认为我们想给出的免责声明之一是，我觉得两个人可能对彼此都有毒，但这并不意味着他们就一定是坏人。
And it doesn't mean that, like, your experience was any less valid because this person, you know, everyone else thinks they're pretty lovely. but like there's a difference I think between a toxic relationship and one that's abusive and the type of character that Cloudy is talking about which is like diagnosably sociopathic and narcissistic but I think toxic relationships can happen between any two people they can have a toxic relationship where two people I just do not have these personality disorders and do you know and I still think it's like completely like an experience that is like quite traumatising like yeah like there was this one person I was like see
并且这并不意味着，你的经历就不那么有价值了，因为这个人，你知道的，其他所有人都觉得他非常可爱。但我觉得，有毒的恋爱关系和虐待性质的关系之间是有区别的，而克劳迪（Cloudy）所说的那种性格，也就是经诊断具有反社会和自恋人格障碍的人——但我认为任何两个人之间都可能发生有毒的恋爱关系，他们可能会陷入一种有毒的关系中，即便这两个人根本没有这些人格障碍，你懂的，而且我依然认为这完全是一种——一种相当创伤性的经历，就像——没错，就像曾经有这样一个人，我当时在
and like it was it was just that anxiety you talk about is just so I can just remember it yeah I was just constantly anxious I was constantly waiting for him to yeah you appreciate me and like and he would say things to me all the time that would just like shoot me down yeah I don't oh like one time he was like oh I would never like properly date you because you're not pure enough yeah I think I told you about and I was like and then but then but then you know the next day he'd be like oh my god like i've had all of these amazing thoughts and i just need to share them with you and i was like what the fuck do you want for me it's the biggest fuck around yeah it's yeah and it's like i don't think that person is a bad person but like the trauma of it
而且就好像——那种你所说的焦虑感真的是太——我简直还能想起来。没错，我当时处于不断的焦虑之中，我一直在等待他——没错，认可我，而且他总是对我说一些会彻底贬低我的话。没错，我不知道，有一次他说，“哦，我永远不会真正和你约会，因为你不够纯洁。”没错，我想我跟你说过这个，然后我说——然后但接着，但接着你知道的，第二天他又会说：“哦天哪，我产生了好棒好棒的想法，我必须跟你分享。”而我就像是在想：“这到底是什么鬼？你到底想从我这里得到什么？”这简直是最大的折腾。没错，这真的是——而且就好像，我不觉得那个人是个坏人，但这种创伤
like yeah well sometimes this is another thing that i read or got told i don't know what it was but sometimes the person doesn't have to be bad but their behavior is yeah and that's still what you're responding to and like in that situation that person was young and And I'm sure they're different now. But, like, oh, some of the other things that happened. Yeah, that's still inexcusable. Yeah, and there was a lot of other things where I was like, he was like, don't tell anyone about this.
就像是，好吧，有时——这是我读到或被告知的另一件事，我不知道是从哪听来的，但有时这个人不一定是坏人，但他们的行为是。没错，而这依然是你做出反应的对象，并且在那种情况下，那个人很年轻，而且我确信他们现在已经不一样了。但是，就像，其他发生过的一些事情。没错，那依然是不可原谅的。没错，还有很多其他的事情，让我觉得，他说：“不要把这件事告诉任何人。”
And then. Yeah. And I was like, well, now I feel like we're accomplices in this thing. But actually, I'm the only one who's, like, burden by it. Like, yeah. And it was just so, and it, like, it took me, like, I'm sure you can speak to this, but, like, months. Yes.
然后。没错。而我就在想，好吧，现在我觉得我们成这事的同谋了。但实际上，承受沉重负担的只有我一个人。没错。这真的是太——而且它花费了我——我确信你能感同身受，但这需要好几个月。没错。
Months. I don't even think I got over it until, like, only a couple of years ago. Well, I don't think, like, person, well, with, like, my experience, it's not something I think I will ever just get over. It was so traumatizing. It's not something like it's always going to be there now. It's always, in some ways it's been good. In some ways I can detect when I dated since like very fast when someone's not good.
好几个月。我甚至觉得直到大概仅仅几年前，我才真正走出来。好吧，我不认为——对于这个人，好吧，就我个人的经历而言，这不是那种我觉得自己永远能彻底放下的事。它太具有创伤性了。这不是那种——它现在会一直都在。它永远都在，在某些方面这其实是件好事。在某些方面，我后来在约会时，能非常迅速地察觉出什么时候某个人是不好的。
I can detect very fast when a behavior is just not okay or not right for me or when someone's just not right for me. But in other ways, like even now I'm in like a lovely, with someone lovely, very healthy relationship. But anything that kind of the tiniest thing that could be to the contrary. and there's like a switch. There's like I will get into kind of defensive mode very like easily. So it's something that you're like, it's still going. It's just three years.
我能非常迅速地察觉出什么时候某种行为根本不对劲，或者不适合我，或者什么时候这个人根本不适合我。但在其他方面，比如现在我正处于一段美好的、跟一个可爱的人在一起的、非常健康的恋爱关系中。但任何哪怕有一点点相反迹象的微小事情发生时。就会像触动了一个开关。就会像——我会非常轻易地进入某种防御模式。所以这是那种——它依然在继续。这已经是三年了。
Yeah. And it's like... It like fully changes the structure of your brain. When someone treats you that way. It does. And like I have the other thing I like, I don't know if you've, if you have the same feeling. Like I haven't really going, I think into this as much. But like the thing I sometimes like sit up way at night thinking about is like I let someone treat me that way.
没错。并且这就好像——它彻底改变了你大脑的结构。当别人那样对待你的时候。确实如此。而且我还有另一种感觉——我不知道你有没有、你是不是也有同样的感觉。就好像我并没有真正去想——我觉得对此并没有想太多。但有时我会半夜坐起来思考的事情是：我竟然允许别人那样对我。
That was how I felt like the first year. Like that entire year that I had first broke it off. Even now I'm like, I like, I like, because I kind of accepted, there was a first of the part was accepting that's his personality, that's how he is. I have to get through that. Once I got through that and accepted,
这就是我第一年的感受。在彻底断联的那整整一年里，我都是这种感觉。甚至现在我还在想，我——我——因为我某种程度上接受了，其中第一部分是接受那是他的性格，他就是那样的人。我必须挺过这一关。一旦我挺过去并接受了这一点：
that's the kind of person he is. Yeah. Yeah, then the guilt goes to you. Then the kind of anger kind of switches and it goes, what the fuck? And I remember this so vividly. It's so good, I remember this so vividly because there was a part,
他就是那种人。没错。没错，然后罪恶感就会转向你自己。然后那种愤怒就会转换方向，变成：“这到底是怎么回事？”我把这记得清清楚楚。太棒了，我把这记得清清楚楚，因为曾经有一个部分、
a point where we did talk again for a bit. I unblocked him. we talked again, he invited me out to a concert or whatever. Initially, I agreed to it, got really, really anxious again. And then I, like, came home, like, an hour or two before the concert. Just, like, started bawling my eyes out, like, all the lights off in my room, the blanket over me, lying in my bed, just thinking over and over the, like, how, what am I doing? Yeah.
有一个阶段，我们确实又聊了一会儿。我把他的黑名单放出来了，我们又聊了聊，他邀请我去听音乐会什么的。起初，我答应了，结果又开始变得非常非常焦虑。然后我——大概在音乐会开始前一两个小时回到家。就像是——开始嚎啕大哭，把我房间里所有的灯都关掉，身上盖着毯子，躺在床上，脑子里不断地反思——我到底在干什么？没错。
Like, how did I let someone treat me like this? Why are I still agreeing to this? Why did I agree to this? And being, like, oh, my God, like, what's going to happen? If I go, like, am I really doing this? Then I was like, what am I doing? And I just sat myself like, thank God, I was like, what the fuck? I have a choice here.
就像，我怎么能允许别人这样对待我？为什么我还在答应这件事？我为什么要答应这个？并且觉得，天哪，接下来会发生什么？如果我去了——我真的要这么做吗？然后我想，我到底在干什么？我对自己说——谢天谢地，我当时想：这到底是怎么回事？我在这里是有选择权的。
That's a thing. You don't feel like you do. I have to say yes. I'm like, oh, I have to. I said yes now. Oh, it's going to be so angry if I say no. Who cares? I was like, get a grip.
关键就在这里。你感觉自己好像没有选择。我只能说好。我就想，哦，我必须去。我都已经答应了。哦，如果我说不去，他会生气的。谁在乎呢？我当时想：振作点。
Yeah. Like, honestly. Get a grip, clarity. I was like, honestly, obviously terrible situation. I was like, I just had to be like, get a fucking grip. Look at you. Look at what? Look at what?
没错。说实话。振作点，克劳迪。我当时想：说实话，这显然是个糟糕透顶的情况。我当时就必须对自己说：他妈的振作点。看看你。看看这是什么？看看什么？
Look at you. You're fucking balling your eyes out and bed with all your lights off. Yeah. Like, go to group, and I was spent to go to my mum's that weekend, and I was like, why would you lie to your mum and blow off your mum? For this man. Yeah, I was like, no, sorry, I was like, you know, I've, like, packed up all my things, we went to the train to my mum's.
看看你。你他妈的正在床上一边开着全黑的灯一边嚎啕大哭。没错。就好像，振作点，而且我本来那天周末要去看我妈的，然后我就想：你为什么要对你妈撒谎，还要放你妈的鸽子？为了这个男人。没错，我当时就想：不，对不起，我当时想：你知道的，我已经——把所有的东西都收拾好，我们去坐去我妈那里的火车了。
Yeah. And just, like, I can't do it. Not going. Not going. And obviously, he called angry. And I was, like, too bad. You don't have, just control me anymore. Yeah, I was like, too fucking bad.
没错。然后就——我做不到。不去了。不去了。毫无疑问，他打来电话时很生气。而我当时想：那太糟糕了。你再也无法控制我了。没错，我当时想：他妈的活该。
But, yeah, that was, like, one of the times. I remember a lot of the times, like, in the aftermath and just healing. And even now sometimes, you know, you still kind of go back and you're like, how the fuck? did I let someone treat me? And it's because like from as well for me like yeah like this could happen to anyone and I in realizing that like I am
但是，没错，那确实是其中的一次。我还记得很多次，比如在事情发生后的那段日子以及疗愈的过程中。甚至现在有时候，你知道的，你还是会回想起来，然后你会想：我他妈的怎么会允许别人那样对我？这是因为——对我来说也是一样，没错——这种事可能会发生在任何人身上，而当我意识到这一点时——我
and I've always been very strong very independent, very confident in myself I've never kind of been anyone who's unsure really of themselves or has a lot of insecurities. So to kind of be like what the fuck how how did I go from kind of the girl in high school
而且我一直以来都是一个非常坚强、非常独立、对自己非常自信的人。我从来都不是那种对自我真正感到不确定或者有很多不安全感的人。所以当我发现——这到底是怎么回事？我怎么会从当年那个在高中里
rejecting every single man and being like not interested fuck you all to fucking like this to literally being on my knees, begging and crying for some person who doesn't give two shits. Yeah, because I find this, it's like with my friends and like when I'm out or when I'm
拒绝每一个男人、摆出一副“不感兴趣，滚一边去”姿态的女孩，变成现在这副他妈的德行？变成那种字面意义上跪在地上、对一个根本不屑一顾的人苦苦哀求和痛哭流涕的样子。没错，因为我发现这一点，就像我和朋友们在一起时，或者当我出门、或者当我
alone, I'm like, wow, I'm genuinely like the best person in the world. Yeah. And I'm like, and I like, even last night I was like lying in bed and it's like then you, I'm just like, how did I? Like, I don't know, we just keep saying this but I just think about it a lot. Like it keeps me up. But then obviously it's good. Like learning about.
独自一人时，我会想：哇，我真心觉得我是世界上最好的人。没错。然后我会想——甚至就在昨晚我还躺在床上，然后就——我就在想：我怎么会？我不知道，我们一直在重复这句话，但我确实经常想起它。这让我彻夜难眠。但显然这也是件好事。比如去了解——
You know, obviously the science behind it, which we haven't even really gone into too much. Well, I think we're going to go into that in the second part of this episode, which we'll probably publish on it like two different ones like the first one. So, yeah, should we go into the science? Yeah, so yeah, pretty much the question that we asked ourselves for a long time, like still, how did we end up in this? In this, yeah. 2%.
你知道的，显然这背后是有科学依据的，而我们甚至还没怎么深入探讨过。好吧，我想我们会在本集节目的第二部分中深入探讨这个，我们可能会把它分成两部分发布，就像第一部分那样。所以，没错，我们要不要探讨一下背后的科学？没错，所以——差不多就是我们长时间以来一直在问自己的问题，现在依然在问：我们到底是怎么落得这般田地的？在这当中，没错。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。在播客《回看过去》（Look Back at a Podcast）中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay），我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host kids.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人主持的《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way）。
games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里探讨的是黑人的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你们是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就非得这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证 本集节目尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。